did you know that in order to film an
intense 27-minute scene the crew of
succession hid roles of film around the
set so the camera operators could reload
without cutting and for the intense
season 4 election Night episode they
hired a former Obama advisor to help
orchestrate the chaos let's take a look
behind the scenes of this iconic show
okay let's just start by saying I'm
doing some huge spoilers here so if you
haven't watched the fourth season of
succession you might want to bail real
quick then head back here after you've
watched okay now that my official Duty
as spoiler alerter is done let's get to
the biggest bombshell of the entire
series Logan Royce death obviously in a
sense it's something everyone was
waiting for
that was not a good feeling yeah no the
character had several near-death
situations over the course of the show
and the dang thing is called succession
AKA who's gonna get the company when he
dies because if we know Logan we knew he
wasn't actually gonna ever retire while
he was alive but they still had to make
the big decisions on how and when to do
it according to writer and creator of
the show Jesse Armstrong a huge Choice
was to not include an actual death scene
this is because he wanted it to feel for
both the characters and the viewers kind
of similar to the way we experience
death in the modern era we wanted to
capture a feeling of death of
communication over phone and email then
there was the style of shooting director
Mark milod was very intentional about
the way he shot it looking to amp up the
intensity and frenetic nature of the
situation it felt to me like the camera
had to be almost sadistically
voyeuristic it had to stay really close
the logistics of the shoot were pretty
challenging too they shot the whole
scene on the boat several times in
chunks but then they decided to try it
as one long shot in one take basically
they were putting on a one-act play on a
boat what we ended up doing we shot like
five or six days and then we ran the
whole thing as it turns out it's like a
27 minute long scene the problem was
that they shot it on film and that meant
they needed to reload the camera every
10 minutes so they came up with an
unusual fix and the camera creatures
worked on this idea of basically hiding
rolls of film around the set one camera
would always be running so they wouldn't
have to reload at the same time but it
was worth it because they got their best
footage from the in one take there was
also the Bold choice of having Logan's
Death happen in only the third episode
leaving the rest of the season without
him milod talked about how it turns
traditional storytelling on its head and
he loved the idea you take all the
places you'd expect such a kind of
humongous event and play the exact
opposite of that and I thought that was
just a brilliant brilliant idea and
Armstrong was averse to the notion that
Logan's death would come at the end of
the season he felt like it would
ultimately be a letdown to have a death
and a funeral and then the show just
like ends we want to see how a death of
someone's significant rebounds around a
family as challenging as filming Logan's
death episode was for the crew it was
equally challenging for the actors this
was in spite of the fact that they also
knew it was coming Jeremy Strong who
plays Kendall Roy talked about how there
was no way to adequately prepare for it
I wasn't terribly surprised I thought it
made sense and then when I read the
script I found it shocking but at the
same time he loved how much it pushed
him as an actor I'll be given something
that I think is this is the limit of
what I'm capable of as an actor you have
no choice but to go through that this
episode was one of those Sarah snook AKA
shiv who was actually pregnant while
filming talked about the real life
stress that comes from filming scenes
where the character is facing serious
stress being in the frame of mind for
two weeks at a time is not healthy she
tried to counter the stress and
intensity and I guess the health of her
baby by emotionally pulling out of her
character whenever the director yelled
cut it also helped keep her performances
fresh and honest for me staying in means
that it does and it's not good the
process was also pretty grueling for
Kieran Culkin who plays Roman not just
emotionally but physically yeah that was
Roman going through some sort of
emotional trauma but I haven't and of
course the decision to kill off Logan
Roy had a direct impact on the actor
playing him Brian Cox hang on this is
one of the greatest pieces of work I've
ever been involved in and suddenly it's
no more when it came to nailing the
election episode The Writers wanted to
keep things realistic yet incredibly
tense election moments kind of keep on
coming in the U.S so it felt legitimate
to have to have another one and while
their ability to craft incredible
narratives and characters is
unquestionable the production and
writing team decided to lean into
someone with actual Big Time political
experience so they they brought in Eric
Schultz to advise them on the script who
was a former political advisor for
President Obama Schultz talked about how
the aim was to make it feel similar to
real life and he admitted that Fox News
calling Arizona for President Biden in
the 2020 election served as some
inspiration the writers are always
looking for real-life analog a fox's
call for Arizona uh in 2020. put them
out on a Ledge a lot of the other
networks were not willing to go there at
that point for Kieran Culkin the
election Night episode was one of his
favorites to play because of the clear
motivation of his character it's really
nice for me when I show up to work and
have to play the character when Roman
has a one clear objective that was a lot
of fun to play the writers have had a
clear motivation for a few years now to
somehow live up to the hype ever since
succession became a smash hit each
season brings more and more pressure for
the writers and creative team to deliver
yeah that's great congratulations
interestingly enough Jesse Armstrong
while writing season 3 found himself a
bit behind schedule this was in early
2020 and he admits to kind of wishing
the world would sort of shut down for a
couple months so he could finish and
spoiler alert with the covid-19 pandemic
it suddenly did and yet the show trudged
on they shot all of season three during
the most locked down time of the early
pandemic this was partially challenging
because they needed to make it seem like
the story was happening in the bustling
Streets of New York City not an easy
task when the entire city is you know
quarantining at home so they had to get
creative with the use of background
actors often just spacing them out
enough to keep them safe while trying to
make it seem like it was a non-pandemic
world like all the Productions that
happened in 2020 and 2021 they had
rigorous testing on set social
distancing masks Etc but unlike in real
life there were moments each day when
the primary actors took off their masks
and got in close proximity for the cast
and crew this was an extra layer of
realness and catharsis it allowed them
to propel themselves into a scene freed
from the restraints of covid if only for
a few minutes at a time because the
actors had all this extra stuff on you
know just before the take come to take
all that stuff off the acting isn't the
only thing that's super raw and real on
succession because if it seems like
you're in the room with the Roy family
as you watch that's not an accident the
series is shot with techniques that aim
to make it feel as real as possible
director Mark mylod talked about how he
prefers to let the actors move around as
they want and let the cameras move with
them as opposed to blocking out each
action he even likened the shooting
style to a theater production it's like
the first day of rehearsing a play the
more geometric the more symmetrical it
becomes the less authentic it always
appears to me he pointed out that if
shots were to be aligned like perfectly
and have the usual geometric shapes of
TV and film it would feel less authentic
so everyone kind of moves around as they
see fit and it's up to the camera
operators to keep shooting them in the
space available now something else that
is authentic perhaps to a fault is
Jeremy Strong's acting technique and
while he doesn't cop to using the famous
method acting that's popular with
thespians he definitely stays in
character long after the scenes have
been shot this didn't always make
working opposite him a lovely experience
a Vanity Fair article about Strong's
process talked about how intense he can
be and how it can be quite let's just
say bothersome to his castmates even the
extras can bear the brunt of it as he
apparently wanted to release real tear
gas in a scene with hundreds of
background actors and there was one time
when he apparently insisted on playing
the kazoo while his scene Partners were
saying their lines it's a little odd and
yet it's hard to argue with the results
Kieran Culkin and Brian Cox didn't speak
highly of Strong's process with Kieran
explicitly saying it's not very helpful
when you're in a scene with strong and
Cox saying that despite warnings about
it strong persisted but Matthew McFadden
who plays Tom wamsganz pointed out that
the whole thing gets way overblown and
it's not the main event considering it's
an ensemble shell speaking of The
Ensemble it was originally set to look a
little different apparently co-creator
Adam McKay gave Jeremy Strong the script
and asked him to choose which character
he connected with strong picked Roman
which eventually went to Kieran Culkin
so strong kind of assumed he was out but
he was asked back to audition for
Kendall and he killed it Culkin
meanwhile auditioned for cousin Greg
which is a hilarious casting to imagine
given the amazing job Nicholas Braun has
done with the role But ultimately
Caulkin admitted that something drew him
to the character of Roman however he
doesn't necessarily think that's a good
thing since Roman is basically a
terrible person hopefully you were
caught up on the show and I didn't just
spoil anything for you but honestly not
much can spoil actually watching the
show Even if you know what's coming have
any thoughts about the behind the scenes
action on succession pop them in the
comments section